haben sie es auch schon gehört die tolle
nachricht die nato krieg zuwachs
die süßen zwillinge heißen finnland und
schweden wir erinnern uns putins
einmarsch in die ukraine sollte eine
ausweitung der nato nach osten
verhindern dafür kriegt er einen nach
norden glückwunsch zum eigentor wladimir
hochverdient schweden
schweden vor 200 jahren neutral am stück
finnland über 70 jetzt treten sie der
nato bei und auf der russischen seite
der grenze ist man menschlich enttäuscht
finnland ist gleich um die ecke die
reaktionen hier reichen von
unverständnis bis ärgern
ich weiß nicht warum die jetzt angst
haben vor uns früher hatten sie keine
ja volk weiß ich warum haben die
plötzlich angst vor russland haben wir
irgendwas gemacht sagt herr putin hat
sich total verrannt er ist völlig
isoliert selbst österreich und die
schweiz diskutieren heutzutage ihre
neutralität und es ist nur eine frage
der zeit bis der vatikan auch nachziehen
ja natürlich
der nato beitritt und schwere waffen bei
rheinmetall bestellen ja logisch
er kann alles tragen ja putin offiziell
verzockt wer legt sich freiwillig mit
den finnen an ein volk das die meiste
zeit des jahres im dunkeln sitz und
schlechte laune hat
übrigens wurde die entscheidende bürger
petition zum nato-beitritt von jungen
finnischen gamern angeschoben wir haben
mit freunden in einem onlinespiel forum
beschlossen dass wir etwas tun sollten
um die finnische nato diskussion endlich
in gang zu bringen alexei und zámbó und
weitere freunde aus ihrem onlinespiel
forum konnten ihre petition einreichen
finnland und die nato das thema war
damit auf der tagesordnung
so putin das ist dein endgegner
freundchen die gefährlichste spezies der
welt computer nerds viele von denen
sprechen nur klingonisch
nebenbei hat finnland aber auch eine top
ausgerüstete armee und allein 900
tausend reservisten unter waffen
schweden wiederum verfügt über
hochmoderne u-boote und alleine 100
kampfflieger ja mit anderen worten
[Applaus]
mit anderen worten schweden und finnland
sind eine echte verstärkung für unser
bündnis jetzt müssen zwar noch sämtliche
mitgliedstaaten zustimmen aber welcher
halbwegs normale mensch könnte da irgend
etwas dagegen haben bitte online oder
nach china wie können wir ihnen trauen
schweden ist eine brutstätte für
terrororganisationen
deine mutter ist eine brutstätte für
nein gott
2009 10 hat die türkei bei putin
flugabwehr raketen gekauft die türkei
als nato land mitten in der größten
krise erpresst der sultan die allianz
experten sagen in wirklichkeit weder die
lieferung von amerikanischen kampfjets
erzwingen die er braucht unter anderem
um kurden in syrien umzubringen schöne
wertegemeinschaft unsere nato oder wer
da alles mitmachen darf wirklich wer da
alles mitmachen nach vitoria
viktor orban und ungarn zb die ebenfalls
auf erpressung setzen er hier droht mit
veto gegen das öl embargo es sei denn
wir erstatten ihm jeden cent verlust was
sind das eigentlich für verbündete wir
arbeiten intensiv mit den ungarn die
haben objektiv einige probleme zu
überwinden zum beispiel ist das ein land
das keine küste hat
ja aber
da können wir jetzt auf die schnelle
nichts dran ändern
man kann ja kein korridor bis zur ostsee
frei sprengen will ja sie meinetwegen
flüssiggasterminals und so vor allem
ungarn und die türkei beweisen so
erfolglos es putin gar nicht bei der
spaltung des westens immerhin zum glück
beim eurovision songcontest da waren wir
uns alle einig und haben die ukraine auf
platz eins gewählt
hat deutschland sage ich auch mitgemacht
platz 66 punkte
höchste zeit für reformideen und zwar
bsc und nato
irgendwer mit medien mit friedrich
küppersbusch
da hat viele menschen hatten ja angst
dass der krieg uns die unschuldige
freude am esc nimmt doch es kam anders
durch die lieferung schwerer punkte aus
ganz europa hat der rsc vielen
russischen staatschefs den spaß am krieg
verdorben ausgerechnet die schlager
selige lgbt gemeinde hat wie wir lanza
sagen den spieß herumgedreht die
buchmacher hatten das in turin der
nächste esc wird in der ukraine
stationiert
damit gerät die nato hier vertreten
durch ursula von der leyen und jens
stoltenberg einmal mehr ins
hintertreffen
wollen wir doch mal vergleichen das
westliche gesangs bündnis hat 40
mitglieder die nato nur 30 die
musikanten engagieren sich politisch für
spendern für den frieden und für das
unbedingte menschenrecht halt singende
altmetall sammlung die tassen im schrank
zu zählen
sie mithalten
die nato dagegen ein hirntod
zerstrittener modisch völlig
hoffnungsloser haufen der ungarn etwa
vergisst ständig wer der feind ist und
der türke erdogan will unbedingt selber
beim esc auftreten
[Musik]
ja richtig geraten das war natürlich das
stinktier beide mast singer außerdem
will erdogan schweden und finnland nicht
dabei haben die knäcke flanke der nato
könnte ihnen beim kurden morden stören
hässliches mobbing also schon in der
vorrunde dabei verfügen gerade die
tapferen finden über die wohl
abschreckende waffe des westens sie
kommen zu harmlos daher wie in
finnischer tanzlehrer
neuer kassier roland
was jetzt hier wurde er nach stimme war
sie sind richtig da links christine
lambrecht beim abschlussball ihres
sohnes in tokio
ja die einzige gemeinsamkeit zwischen
der nato und dem esc die deutschen
landen immer auf dem letzten platz schon
achtmal bisher also 45 nicht
mitgerechnet vielleicht ist es also
gerade an und deutschen die beiden
formate endlich zusammen zu führen der
ndr will das noch nicht wahrhaben aber
im verteidigungsministerium sind die
planungen dazu bereits weit
fortgeschritten hören wir den
singer-songwriter unter den panzer
generellen dr christian freuding und so
das gefecht der verbundenen waffen muss
ich im prinzip vorstellen wie ein großes
sinfoniekonzert
die instrumente müssen zusammen einen
guten klang ergeben schön weggetreten
beide organisationen wurden in den
fünfzigern groß mit ländern die eben
noch gegeneinander krieg führten beide
haben inzwischen russland als ihren
wahren gegner erkannt glauben wir also
an eine bessere zukunft in der wir eines
tages sagen werde nach kommen die nato
da ist doch nur der bewaffnete arm des
esc
irgendwer mit medien mit wieskötter
stosch
jede des körpers tisch
legt erst seehofer warum nicht
mal eine persönliche frage fühlen sie
zuhause sich auch gerade so entlastet ja
das liegt sehr wahrscheinlich am großen
entlastungspaket der ampel 300 euro für
alle steuerpflichtigen erwerbstätigen
200 für sozialleistungsempfänger und 100
für kinder keiner wurde vergessen also
außer die 25 millionen rentnerinnen und
rentnern die kriegen leider nix keine
ahnung warum
und durchaus peinlich für eine regierung
unter spd führung aber ich wette da
arbeiten die sozen längst mit hochdruck
daran wenn ich mir ansehe dass wir zum
beispiel manche rentnerinnen und rentner
haben mit sehr niedrigen renten die aber
keine grundsicherung im alter noch kein
wohngeld zuschuss bekommen dann verstehe
ich dass es dort noch fragen in unsere
richtung gibt und das werden wir ganz
aufmerksamen auch weiterhin begleiten
auch wie aufmerksam oder mehr kann man
nicht tun leute es gibt so viele rentner
in deutschland die unschuldig in not
geraten ja zum beispiel zb
das entlastungspaket der ampel ist in
jedem fall gut gemeint und ein wichtiges
signal aber es ist sozial total
unausgewogen tatsächlich landet der
größte teil der insgesamt
23,6 milliarden paket bei menschen mit
hohem einkommen das ist so zb dank tank
rabatt drei monate lang wird die
benzinsteuer um circa 30 und die
dieselsteuer um 14 cent gesenkt
konsequenz je mehr ich verbrauche mit
meiner karre desto mehr spaß
urania hat meine klar es profitieren
natürlich auch pendler mit niedrigem
einkommen und berufsfahrer ein schönes
von innerhalb von einer minute von 2009
auf 2 049 gestiegen das ist ja edel
innerhalb von einer minute nur weil ich
einmal gewendet habe kostet der liter
sprit 4 cent mehr in dem tipps drei
jahren jetzt soll ja nicht etwa ein mal
kurz kann jetzt muss ich das auto
verkaufen
für ihn und seine kollegen freut mich
das natürlich mit der sprit
steuersenkung aber wann das würde mich
interessieren senken sie die
mehrwertsteuer auf lebensmittel
wann bei den bei den
einkommensschwächsten 20 prozent in
deutschland macht die mehrwertsteuer
zwei drittel ihrer steuerlast aus da
muss man ansetzen der staat könnte statt
7 prozent auf grundnahrungsmittel auch 0
prozent kassieren warum machen wir das
nicht hartz-iv-empfänger müssen sich
klar machen kriegen am tag fünf euro für
lebensmittel das reicht noch für eine
halbe paprika gott ist das deprimieren
komm lass uns darüber was lustiges reden
dass neun euro ticket für neun euro drei
monate lang mit bus und bahn über
geilomat das könnte diesen sommer für
pendlerinnen und pendler vor allem
bedeuten zusammenrücken wendet neuen
euro ticket kommen sollte dann wird
jetzt doch auf jeden fall explodieren
meine damen und herren aufgrund des
neuen euro tickets wird die regionalbahn
nach altenbeken leider explodieren
wir bitten dies zu entschuldigen nein
natürlich hat der mann den wir gerade
gesehen haben recht eigentlich müsste
man vor start des neuen euro tickets
deutlich mehr züge und personal besorgen
deutlich so wie es jetzt läuft
ist chaos vorprogrammiert
abgesehen davon reden hier von einem
marsch teuren strohfeuer das kaum
autofahrer dauerhaft in die öffis lockt
es braucht langfristige investitionen um
das bahnfahren noch attraktiver zu
machen
als es jetzt schon ist höchste nach zehn
minuten fahrt wird es kurz unangenehm
wir hören es plätschern nachdem ein mann
ohne hose einsteigt und wechseln den
platz
da war noch ein platz frei
welche bahn war das denn im
koalitionsvertrag der ampel steht die
bahn solle zitat rückgrat der mobilität
werden auch im ländlichen raum leider
wurde dieses noble vorhaben wegen der
haushaltslage aufs achtung abstellgleis
gefahren
gibt es überhaupt noch gute nachrichten
von der bahn analogen alles wird
insofern anders als die als bisher denn
die scheiben der älteren zug
generationen lassen die ihm neo den also
alles anders als die schreiben älterer
zu generationen lassen die im neo
mobilfunk durch und verbessern so den
empfang im zug ganz erheblich
irgendwas mit scheiben
sind jetzt anders keine ahnung kann
auch beim neuen euro ticket werden
übrigens ganze bevölkerungsgruppen
einfach komplett ausgespart stichwort
landbevölkerung was habe ich von einem
neuen euro ticket wenn in meinem kopf
der bus nur jeden zweiten donnerstag bei
vollmond fährt und dann auch noch in die
falsche richtung was habe ich davon
denkt man aber vorsicht selbst in
solchen traurigen dörfern kannst du
deinen neuen euro ticket super
gebrauchen was weiß ich zum beispiel als
lesezeichen für das dicke buch das zu
komplett lesen kannst du während du auf
den bus wartet der nie kommt oder war
man ja auf dem land ist und natürlich
ständig in kuhscheiße tritt einfach mit
dem neuen euro ticket aus der schuhsohle
polen und wenn dann nach stunden immer
noch kein bus in sicht ist kannst du mit
dem neuen euro ticket astrein das
lagerfeuer anzünden dass du dringend
braucht um die hungrigen wölfe
fernzuhalten
schon hoch
gleich ein paar leute auf den trichter
ab montag kann man sich das ticket
online buchen und ab erster juni geht es
dann richtig los das abenteuer 9 euro
ticket am besten man bereitet sich vor
19 euro service it oriel mit alexander
wipprecht
viele von euch werden bald zum ersten
mal ein öffentliches verkehrsmittel
benutzen das wird ein schock aber keine
angst ich bereite mich vor auf den
albtraum zur arbeit fahren mit bild
wiedl und fremdenpolitik
sorry das war jetzt nicht persönlich
gemeint
so ganz wichtiger unterschied auto zu
hause fährt erst los wenn ihr drin sitzt
der bus so absurd es klingt fährt zu
bestimmten zeiten einfach ab und wegen
des neuen euro tickets wird das ein
tierisches gedränge und deshalb müsst
ihr rechtzeitig erkennen wenn die
schwächsten im fahrgast rudel sind
kinder zb oder dieser mann hier dem habe
ich eben die schnürsenkel
zusammengebunden
dumme menschen nicht leid aber so ist
jetzt eben unsere neuen euro welt
einige werden das einfach nicht schaffen
und was dann kommt kann man leider nicht
beschuldigen auf ein paar pnv horror
classics müsste ich mental vorbereiten
niemand weiß wann man aber in jedem bus
gibt es immer gehören da in dem sein
dünner komplett alles nur schmeckt er
möglichst viele leute dabei zugucken und
riechen
noch schlimmer ist nur der blue chips
durch drittmittel um bot er sich aus
irgendwelchen gründen immer noch
irgendetwas umgedrehten muss man auch
ich selber super idee dass mal ein euro
ticket ausgerechnet im sommer
einzuführen wo sowieso alle positiv
[Musik]
das ist meine brieftasche
leute ja ihr habt den bus erfolgreich
gemeistert klickt jetzt mein nächstes
video etwa pmv survivor
umstellen
was nun mit alex kuprecht
[Applaus]
so ihre zuschauer
was mir auffällt ein großteil der
berichterstattung zum 9 euro ticket
dreht sich um die frage was das alles
für die insel sylt bedeutet ja man
mutmaßt dass der sylter an sich wenig
bock hat auf einen ansturm von
normalverdienern es ist es ist nein es
ist wirklich absurd was da teilweise für
uralte sylt klischees gepflegt hat wir
schalten wir live zu matthias matschke
vom verband der sylter
ferienhausbesitzer matschke verstehen
sie die ganze aufregung neuer wege für
sie mag das für recht amüsant sein aber
für echte sylter also menschen mit
immobilienbesitz saßen rolle neurotiker
sowas wie hurrikan katrina damals in den
usa und will mir gar nicht vorstellen
was da auf uns zurollt meine frauen
elvira gestern google was an diesem
ballermann so passiert die bilder diese
lieder das erbrochene
war sehr gut wir waren jetzt hier auf
einen der letzten flucht hubschrauber
flucht habe ein bisschen dramatisch
vielleicht oder aja hier am strand von
kampen sehe ich freunde die versuchen
ihren letzten habseligkeiten von der
insel zu bringen bevor der pöbel den
strand flutet wie die alliierten die day
sie können zusätzlich sehen aber da
vorne angeht überall flucht
alexander ducati mit wieder gestoppt
werden
die menschen vergessen so steht ich sage
nur 1995 das wochenendticket das war
doch genau die gleiche scheiße die bahn
führt das wochenendticket die
ankommenden menschenmassen auf sylt
damals nicht von allen erwünscht das ist
ein so großer billigtourismus für drei
marca person und wir drei mal für eine
fahrkarte ausgibt hat wahrscheinlich
nicht mal drei mal klarstellte
ältere sollte erinnert sich mit
schaudern heißt du noch 95 als 10.000
vokuhila frisuren und eigenen
tupperdosen aus den stinkenden zügen
gequollen sehen hier so soll das damals
am strand von westerhever
dürfen nie wieder von deutschem boden
ausgehen herr welke schon ohne nun euro
tickets sind nach soll im sommer am
himmel diese insel ist schlecht nicht
dafür gemacht dass jeder einfach
herkommen und deshalb
springt der fremdenverkehrsverband heute
den hindenburgdamm
das schafft verschaffen uns mehr zeit
die menschen haben schlicht angst einige
makler befürchten schon die
grundstückspreise auf sylt könnten bald
runter gehen auf hamburger niveau also
dritte welt
jetzt wird er wahr
der computerbauer
finde ich froh dass wir ganz ohne
südliche ist ausgekommen sind passiert
viel
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mime hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
scheiß und sie tippen - wollt dann
abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]